Senator Cory Booker is a member of the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee and a
candidate for the Democratic
presidential nomination this morning
Booker unveiled his new plan to prevent
gun violence in the United States
it calls for a national gun licensing
program to keep guns out of the wrong
hands his plan would also ban assault
rifles limit handgun purchases to one a
month and close loopholes that allow
abusive partners to buy guns it's a part
of our series the road to 20-20-20
senator Booker joins us first on CBS
this morning to reveal the details of
his plan good morning senator we should
also mention that Gail is good friends
with the senator and has supported him
in the past why should we mention that
my Booker Mike Cory Booker T shirt at
home right forcing these that she has to
be tougher question right exactly well
we've gotten that out of the way tell us
senator what do you think of this new
with respect to Iran I worry about the
policy we have with Iran a president
pulled out of an Iran deal really
turning his back on our allies has done
things that have created in my opinion
more dysfunction in the region tweeting
out that you're going to pull troops out
of Syria which is a highway Iran is
using to help get arms and resources to
Hezbollah I don't see any comprehensive
strategy and this saber-rattling is
something that concerns me clearly Iran
is a a real threat to the region of the
security of Israel it's something that
we should be doing in a more coordinated
fashion with our allies to check Iranian
aggression but we heard from the
national security adviser that this
threat emerged in likely last 24 to 48
hours what is the threat there was a
solution to some threat to US forces
again I don't have the details on that
but again we have to have a
comprehensive strategy we can't do
foreign policy by tweet we need to have
a real strategy around Iran and we
should not have sort of the sound the
trumpets of war trying to engage us in
unnecessary more military engagements
we've wasted as we know from a war going
into an a false pretences we have seen
trillions of dollars of expense in this
region without a plan without a strategy
to really achieve what we must have
which is peace and security
let me ask you now to switch to your
your a new plan on guns why is the
licensing guns the solution well first
of all it's evidence-based we know it
works and states like Connecticut that
have done it they have seen 40 percent
drops in gun violence 15 percent drops
in suicide rates but this is a bigger
issue in America where we're not
approaching it or taking it on in
proportion to the gravity of the
consequences of our inaction every day
in America we have in the aggregate a
mass shooting ripping apart communities
over 100 people dying of gun violence we
form governments to protect for the
common defense and here we have in my
lifetime more people being killed by gun
violence in every single war in our
country's history from the Revolutionary
War now combined we must step up and
deal with something that is crushing
communities destroying lives and really
just tearing apart families one of the
push backs is you licensed guns you make
it more difficult for the honorable gun
owner to get there to engage in their
Second Amendment right and the people
who want to get guns and shoot each
other in the street are gonna do it I
know because no one enforces the law
that kind of resignation frustrates me
to be honest because we know that this
is not a plan that any law buying
governor should be concerned about the
people that should be concerned about it
are two groups one people who want to
break the law
Gun Runners and criminals and the gun
manufacturers who have been working
within an ungodly way to undermine the
safety and security of this nation
really attacking everything from
consumer product safety to the CDC's
ability to research these issues to even
the ATF which is starved by Congress and
its inability to even enforce the laws
we have you are certainly no stranger
accorded gun violence in the City of
Newark I think most people in the
country thought after the Newtown
shooting the gun laws would change after
Parkland the gun laws would change
nothing people say has changed why do
you think that this is going to make a
difference now
well first most politicians even stay
away from this issue because it's such a
hot button well I can't stay away from
this issue because this is not some
policy issue out there this is an
everyday experience to people like me
and people folks in my community
I had a young man die from an assault
rifle attack yes last year just a couple
of days ago three people shot in my
neighborhood and I'm not unique this is
happening all over the country ripping
apart communities and that's why I'm
gonna be a president that this is not
thoughts and prayers faith without works
is dead I'm gonna bring a fight to this
issue in a comprehensive manner like the
NRA has never seen before there's an
urgency in my life that a lot of
Americans are feeling who are afraid to
go to their houses of worship afraid to
let their kids go to school there's an
urgency that I feel on this issue that
is very personal to me having witnessed
the consequences of our inaction and we
are going to fight and we're gonna win
I'm curious how your campaign is going
whenever they do the top five candidates
we're now 21 candidates in you were
never in the top five are you concerned
about that are you thinking that you're
breaking through you think you're doing
okay because when you look at the
numbers it's like oh no yeah well I've
no concern about that at this point this
far out that you'd be concerned no the
people who are usually leading in the
polls this far out it's much more about
name recognition and we have seen from
John Kerry to Barack Obama this part far
out the polls did not indicate
ultimately who won what's important to
me is getting out there and talking to
voters and when I go to Iowa or South
Carolina the response we're getting is
incredible the people signing up on our
campaigns the over 70,000 Americans who
have given small dollar contributions to
my campaign we've got the fundamentals
and we've got the message and I'm
excited about this campaign all right
and if you become president will rosario
dawson be first lady i knew you were
gonna ask such a question i was just
reading that other reason i will talk to
you about my love life off the air like
we usually do my girlfriend as well
she's watching making senator Booker
thank you